après tu es payé ok préparation des
commandes d'épicerie pour les personnes
de 70 ans et plus aux alentours de saint
michel des saints
le livreur série j'envoie le maire de la
municipalité car je m'étais impliqué
mais c'était pour les gens quelqu'un
comme moi on va et revient sur la côte
nord
les roms sont plus sécurisés les
employés ou s'ils sont plus utilisés
mais ça ne garantit de garder un épicier
du voile ou une pharmacie ouverte
en route vers la première cliente
batterie si j'ai encore passé lui qui
m'est arrivé la semaine passée puis la
chance qu'ils vivent encore aujourd'hui
lise champagne s'est bien acclimaté à la
nouvelle réalité est là vous n'avez pas
de visite
je me disais que je n'avais pas avec sa
population de 2004 sans âme
la petite ville n'a techniquement pas
encore enregistré un seul cas
d'infection au virus et aimerait que ça
reste ainsi
mais au pays du chalet de saison le
décompte des résidents monte à 10 milles
bref l'inquiétude vient de l'extérieur
il vient des six états en commun qu'on
veut à vivre au trône et l'île de man
vous dire on aimerait savoir l'été mais
là la sépulture est chez vous le si vous
mets au chalet est le seul à rester au
chalet c'est ce qu'a fait andré payant
un résident de saint-hubert qui ne le
regrette pas
dans l'hiver souvent quand tu rêves dans
la maison appartement je connais pas ton
voisin quand jusque dans une petite
municipalité tout les gens se
connaissent se côtoient side centraide
service
à l'heure de la pause c'est le dépanneur
du coin qui concocte le repas de midi
pour remporter la spéciale pas se lasser
couëron et un jean legros magasin
général avec la censure
c'est ce qui fait que
monde du
je voyais bien comme ça
saint michel des saints n'a pas de kde
coronavirus vous allez enfin presque car
le maire lui a été touché de plein fouet
mois avant la semaine de relâche sa
femme et sa belle-mère on rejouait en
europe
la fille aînée qui était en vacances et
ils sont revenus contaminé sa belle-mère
a même failli passer ils sont encore
deux semaines 1 40 m à balma focale et
apprennent à marcher
tai pan d'énergie parce que a été hué jo
un verrou et huberdeau remis pour avec
un guide jungle les trois femmes sont en
isolement depuis le début en appartement
à joliette
sans aucun contact avec eux maintenant
vous n'avez pas embrasser votre femme
vous de fil mais ça fait depuis belle ma
fille depuis le mode jarry parce que
parce que mon avis puis ma femme depuis
le vendredi à mal la semaine dans la lch
une fois par semaine réjean gouin leur
livre aussi l'épicerie je veux amener la
caramella tué son support l'impact du
recul de 3 m quel est l'impact y sommes
c'est dans les films l'aleps autour du
paisible lac la vie c'est donc
réorganiser loin des centres urbains la
municipalité a réussi aussi à préserver
ses aînés du virus avec des mesures
prises dès le début de la crise ce qu'on
a demandé aux employés c'est de faire
comme si eux mêmes avait 70 ans et plus
donc quand son port travail faute à la
maison c'est les conjoints de fond les
commissions qui vont chercher les choses
contre vents et marées la municipalité
donc épargné par la coved 19
mais pour combien de temps c'est ce
c'est panique s est tu sais pas c'est
quelque chose que je pense dans ma vie
je veux à l'apport attendu de vie mais
et qu'on est dedans mais faut traverser
il faut traverser la rivière vont
intéresser autres forêts et lacs sont
mères éternel optimiste veille au grain